the Washington National Cathedral has
replaced its stained glass with BLM type
propaganda four new stained glass
windows just this past Saturday
dedicated to the theme of racial Justice
and those installations were to replace
the previous windows which depicted
Stonewall Jackson which depicted Robert
E Lee which depicted some of the great
figures of the South my first thought is
episcopalians are going to Episcopalian
that's right I said it you know this is
what they do listen some of my very best
friends are Episcopalian okay but
there's that good old line variously
attributed to Dean Inge or Fulton Sheen
which is that if you wed the spirit of
the age you'll find yourself a widow in
the next and the episcopalians gotta
love them but they have particularly
fallen into this trap